[Music]
this is
the ramsay show
can be intentional about your character
you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice kristy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five as we
take your calls about your life
and your money that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five
well the book is launched it's been open
available for pre-sale pre-order uh for
about a week and sales are brisk doing
very well take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance is
here
uh or we'll be here soon and we're
selling it now it comes out pre-sale the
actual launch date is september 14th
september 14th is when it'll be mailed
to your mailbox
and of course if you pre-purchase take
back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance you
will get the e-book
the audiobook and a lot of other goodies
go to ramseysolutions.com hit the store
and uh christy wright's brand new book
uh will be there it will be a number one
it's
already selling faster than uh
than than any of us imagine we hoped it
would do really good yeah but it is uh
it's a kind of uh we're all like wow
yeah i think it shows what a pain point
this is for people because
especially when you look at last year
with covid and then now life is getting
back to busy and we're kind of going
what does this even look like and uh
and we had we had a breather there for a
minute where we didn't have to
you know like uh be frenetic and
stressed out
and now it's like back to it it's right
back to it and i think too you start to
realize gosh i've tried to manage my
calendar i've tried
different apps and different planners
and the problem keeps creeping up and
that's why i love
in this book getting to the root behind
our problem with our time
and then we can fix it there and then
watch how it fixes the calendar so
it's really a different perspective on
life balance which i'm excited about
so if you feel like no matter how much
you check off your to-do list it's never
enough like you're always
just pulled and pushed and torn and
end of the day ragged out well you need
to take back your time
and christy will show you how with this
new book it is a it's a great read
some great very clear principles that
you can apply to your life
and uh and uh you will immediately
identify with her and her stories all
the way through the thing
uh on top of that we are
doing next wednesday the 28th
the life balance with christy wright you
can join a free session
at 7 p.m on youtube or facebook and you
won't learn what life balance is what it
isn't
and what the root cause of why you feel
out of balance how to achieve balance so
you can
actually enjoy your life uh and so how
do you
get involved with this free life balance
event uh next wednesday the 28th
at 7 00 pm central time on youtube or
facebook well you go to
ramseysolutions.com
balance and you need the rsvp and we
will send you the link
yep get your spot once you rsvp and give
us your info we'll send you a link it's
completely free
no salesman will call uh and uh it's all
on this whole subject of
taking back your time ramsay solutions
dot com slash balance for the event next
wednesday
the 28th with christy wright lots of
good stuff going on
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life your balance
your money your lack of any of those uh
lack of life lack of balance and lack of
money we can talk about that and how to
get more of each uh yeah it's a good
idea
and um you know this is a great
timely subject because it's one of the
most misunderstood areas
where there's a lot of toxic uh shaming
almost the self-shaming on this whole
idea of
i gotta get balanced i gotta get
balanced so i'm balanced oh no i'm not
balanced
and so you just can't you can't really
do it and so there's a way to
get control of your life and it's called
taking back your time where you are in
control again
it's interesting when you control your
time and you control your money
oh i think we have control of our life
that's so true and it gives you a sense
of control that
has a ripple effect less anxiety less
stress
less worry more peace more confidence
more fulfillment
more enjoyment of your life like watch
the ripple effect of
if you can get control of these two
areas of your life it's huge and the
parallels like we always say dave
between time and money is is is very um
very consistent exactly again open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five ben is in detroit to
start off this hour
hey ben how are you good yourself sir
better than i deserve how can i help
uh so my wife and i are wrapping up baby
step three in october
i'm 26 and she's 21. and we want to make
sure we follow your plan to the letter
um i'm worried i have too much house and
my question is should i sell it and
downsize
or do i just power through baby step six
well um what makes you think you have
too much house
uh just be worried we're not following
these 25 percent of your take home pay
rule
oh i see okay all right but you've made
it through you're you're
out of debt and you're ready to start
your
i mean you're finishing up your uh
emergency fund then you're going to be
ready to start 15
of your income into retirement are you
going to be able to do that
correct yes okay so what what is the uh
what percentage of your take-home pay is
your house payment
uh about 30 okay
35 but it's not a 30 year yeah okay
it's not a deal breaker uh i don't think
you have to move down
uh but you just need to be aware of it
because here's the other thing at your
all's age
and you're at the beginnings of your
career uh you have to be
unless you started at 12. and so um
uh you know you're you're going to see
in the coming five to 10 years
pretty substantial chances to increase
your income as your career moves along
aren't you
yes very true yeah and so that's going
to change that number
pretty quickly uh to where it's not
going to be 30
anymore it's going to be 25 and then
it's going to be a 30 year 15 years so
you're going to be able to lean in on
this house it's just
it may be in the next 36 months you're
not going to lean on it really hard
okay if i am based on projections of my
income
in recent years and side hustles i'm
projecting about
eight years finishing up baby step six
would you consider that uh
normal yep right on yeah the typical
total money makeover financial peace
university graduate that leans in is
done
with the home in seven to eight years so
that that's about right okay
that's a pretty sure thank you you're
doing good you're doing awesome
well well done to be in your early 20s
and be in that position
debt-free working on how that's awesome
and as intentional
yes really looking at everything making
sure what do we got to do
so what we're saying is is you're going
to be a baby steps millionaire by the
time you're 30. yeah
that you know or not before she's 30 i'm
sorry you said eight years he was 26 i
think whitney yeah but yeah so
by the time you're 35 you know you'll be
a baby steps millionaire you'll be there
because you're gonna have a nice home
that's paid for and you're going to have
during that time been putting 15 percent
away of your of your income
and yeah you're going to be in really
good shape congratulations
very very very well done
well that's what we do it's all about
you we talk about you
right in front of you kristy wright
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my
co-host today this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you
make the most out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author
new book is on sale the pre-order the
actual book comes out in september
and we're taking pre-orders now and the
pre-order package is a dreamy dreamy
deal you get all kinds of goodies
the book is take back your time the
guilt-free guide
to life balance jump on
ramseysolutions.com and get your
pre-ordered copy and all the goodies
that go with it the oe book the
audiobook and
tickets to things and oh man we're just
giving you access to all kinds of
goodies you don't want to miss out
dina is with us dina's in virginia beach
hi dina how are you
hi dave i'm doing great today i just
want to tell you it's an honor to be
speaking with you on
like a walking billboard for you oh
thank you
thank you i need walking billboards
i gave your book to everybody at
christmas time including myself
as a gift and it's been a game changer
and a life changer for me
i'm currently on baby step two and
by the end of september i will have paid
off
all of my debt awesome good for you
i'm really really excited about it but
in looking
for uh to the future my question to you
is interesting and it's i've got a
a unusual opportunity i'm looking to
purchase my first home
i'm currently in a rental that i've been
in for 11 years
it's dirt cheap in the best possible
area
that i could ever want to be in i'm just
wondering if i should look to purchase
this house
which would give me an instant
investment because it is a duplex
or should i try to do something on a
smaller scale and look for something
else a smaller single family or a condo
for myself
the one you're living in is coming up
for sale
well uh the situation is that the
landlord
is a very old old man
and we have had discussions in the past
about him giving me
basically a first right to purchase um
it would be an amazing opportunity due
to the location
um it is on my vision board i have
such a vision for what i would want to
do with this so if you bought it there's
a lot of unknowns
if you bought it um uh okay i think i
just heard you're gonna do a lot of
renovation did i just hear that
eventually i would i would be able to
continue living in it
um while saving for res
renovations okay and if you don't have a
tenant
can you make the payment at 50 at um 25
of your take-home pay yeah
um
that that that's that's kind of the
issue
um i am just starting
to save um so ultimately my question
rolls to how what is the best way for me
to save
for this whether it's this house or
another house i know i'm kind of all
over the place
it's just beyond the you know you you
get your emergency fund in place and
baby step three and then you start
saving for a down payment on a house
and then the only question is whether
you buy that house or not and can you
afford it
and um uh duplexes are
um good in that you have a tenant
and that you have some income off of
them uh the great news is the tenant is
next door
the bad news is the tenant is next door
i got lucky with the tenant because i
was able to choose
the tenant i'm a i'm a realtor you
always get to choose the tenant but
they're always next door
correct when you own the house you get
to choose 18
i get to choose who lives over there but
they're next door
and that that creates boundary potential
boundary issues and all kinds of things
you really have to work through you have
to think about that
the other downside is when you get ready
to sell
a duplex the typical buyer of a duplex
is not an owner occupied
the typical buyer is a real estate
investor
and real estate investors have a
tendency to buy things at wholesale not
at retail
and so consequently duplexes at the same
price
say a 200 000 duplex versus a 200 000
single family single family sells at
retail to another to another user
and consequently they will generally
appreciate
more than duplex as well because
because of who your buyer market is your
buyer market is a wholesale buyer on the
duplex and it's a retail buyer on the
other
so as long as you understand those
things going in and you don't have some
kind of false uh romantic version of
what being a landlord is
with having people next door um i mean
you know you could open up a farm and
have a bunch of ghosts right
i've been there somebody did that
seemed like such a good idea at the time
yeah that's what i'm talking about
but that's a great that's a great
example really because
uh sometimes we get an idea in our head
of what something's gonna be like
and the reality is very different so i i
mean you're so on point of like thinking
through what are the actual implications
of this arrangement that and is that
what you want or would you rather
buy something else where you're not
dealing with someone so um
yeah it's sometimes we need to think
through the good the bad and the ugly
not just the good that we're excited
about
yeah if you get sideways with a tenant
they they are
um you know they something
life event happens and they decide
they're not gonna pay because they're
gonna take care of the life event
whatever that is yeah and uh even if you
uh
want to have some mercy on them and and
let them have some time or something
that's okay but at some point they gotta
pay or leave and if you get sideways
with them and they are literally one
wall away
that can be a thing well i'm just
thinking even too every time she walks
out her front door
if they just have new things that they
want to complain about like oh the
water's too hot or
the pain is chipping or you know you're
right there to complain to
all day every day i don't do light bulbs
i know but my light bulb's out yeah
yeah and you're right there yeah that's
exactly what you've got so you have to
have real boundary
discussions and you have to observe good
boundaries you can't just run over there
and knock on the door all the way sure
so uh but it's just um
it's a it's a different thing
emotionally and relationally
to to have them right next door julie is
with us julie's in bend oregon
hi julie how are you good i'm so excited
to talk to you guys this is my first
time calling
any radio show wow thanks for calling
we're honored thank you for joining us
how can we help okay well
i've been doing your program um for
a couple years and my husband and myself
both actually i should say
and we recently sold our house it was a
good time to sell in our area
and we are kind of trying to simplify
and scale down
so we're moving into um one of our
rental houses
but now we've sold our house and we have
this you know chunk of money
and we want to tithe on it um and we we
go to a church regularly tied
there and my her sister her husband are
pastors so he ties to their church too
but i just i'm nervous about how do you
tithe on a big chunk of money
should you put it all in one place
um and you know seeking god asking for
wisdom and all that but
this kind of wanted your opinion on um
you know what what's the best way to
tithe and do you break it up or
just put it all in one big pot
well uh how much did you gain
on the house would you pay for it versus
what you sold it for
well we we came out with after we paid
off um
the mortgage part that was left we have
a million
and or just a little bit yeah but what
did you pay for the house
and what did you sell the house for well
okay i hear what you're saying so we
built back in um oh
and i think we had about 800
on our first you know mortgage no it's
not your mortgage darling
i'm asking what you paid for the house
minus what you paid for it is your gain
and that's what technically if you want
to get a technical biblical answer
that's what you would tithe on
your net increase your net increase has
nothing to do with the mortgage
the mortgage is not a part of the
formula so it's what you sold it for
minus that and technically you
would tithe to your local church now if
your local church has an annual budget
of 300 000 and you're getting ready to
give them 100 000 bucks
that's going to be a problem because
you're going to upset the old apple cart
there and you may want to think about
how you place that
but that's your technical answer uh
overall though god's not mad at you when
you're giving
so just just let's just keep giving at
the forefront and not get
too twisted up on the technicalities
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host
today open phones at 825.
dr john deloney will join me next week
for an entree leadership
theme hour which means that as you're
calling me
with business questions or if you've got
questions about business if you're
dealing with uh things around business
like stress
or like problem team members
or problem family situations in your
family business or something like that
uh gosh dr d would be the one to answer
your question and help you with that
i'll always have an opinion you can
count on that i got one about everything
so uh but either way you can let us know
your entree leadership question
particularly if it falls in those
categories
just go ahead and email kelly now at
dave on air
at ramseysolutions.com dave ramsey
solutions.com just put entree leadership
in the subject line or something like
that and a little bit about what you
want and kelly i'll get back with you
and make you a caller on the
entree leadership theme hour with dr
john deloney and
me on the debt-free stage in
the lobby of ramsey solutions
andrew and nikki are with us hey guys
how are you
living the dream love it love it where
do you guys live
grand rapids michigan oh fun welcome to
nashville
good to have you guys all the way here
to do a debt-free scream how much have
you paid off
165 thousand dollars
okay how long does take seven years 11
months
wow and your range of income during that
time
uh range between 90 000 and 115
okay so i'm gonna guess with that amount
of money that that might be your
mortgage
yeah way to go it is you paid off the
house
looking at weird people seven years
11 months just like i was telling that
caller earlier in the hour that's about
what it takes on average
look at you guys what's this house worth
it's worth about 325
000 now it's all yours
i love it congratulations you guys that
is so
amazing very very well done
oh man so powerful huh so tell us the
story what happened so
we got married uh nine and a half years
ago and as a wedding gift
my brother and sister-in-law gave us a
financial piece
and totally money makeover and i'm not
much of a reader so at the time i didn't
pick them up and read them and a few
months after getting married
we wanted to buy a house so we went and
saw a realtor
friend of ours and um turns out he was
probably one of your um
endorsed local providers before we even
knew what one of those were
yeah and so we went to him and we had 40
000
of student loan debt and we said hey we
want to buy a house
and he said uh focus on getting the
student loan debt done first
and then i'll sell you a house in about
a year year and a half after you get
that done wow
and then he gave us a copy of financial
peace he wrote a nice
note in there and he he talked to us as
if we were his own kids
wow just and so i walked out
really confused i was like why is a
a realtor who makes a living off of
selling homes not selling us a house
yeah and number two why does everyone
keep giving us these books
so we went back and we read the books
together
and we got the student loans
paid off and she got a house shortly
thereafter
and all the debt was done but we never
felt comfortable
having the the house payment having the
mortgage
so right from the beginning we just said
okay
we're not gonna be in debt with a
mortgage for long and
we're gonna try to pay it off as quickly
as possible and uh
five years ago we were pregnant with our
our first child
and we said uh by the if we make the
right sacrifices now
by the time this child is five uh by the
time we're done with the house they're
not even gonna remember
any of the sacrifices that we made let's
just we looked at each other and said
how where do you want to be
and we decided that we were going to be
really weird so
we went gung-ho on the mortgage five
years ago and
got the last payment out in march
that is amazing what was the what was
the hardest part
of making those sacrifices with little
kids because little kids i'm in that
season y'all like it's no joke it's hard
on its own
tell me a little bit about what what
that was like the habits you got into
um you know i think why the
hardest things was maybe not
necessarily going on we still went on a
couple vacations but
um not going on maybe as many vacations
as what we
would have pictured doing with the with
the kettles
because it is really fun to see their
faces light up when
when they're having a good time or
whatnot
yeah and now you can take all the
vacations you can do whatever you want
okay who
what who were your biggest cheerleaders
and what kept you motivated like how did
you how did you stay with it for the for
the long haul
yeah i think our biggest cheerleaders
were my brother and sister-in-law
who gave us the first books we were able
to
discuss with them how our progress and
just encouraging us along the way
and then yeah just what kept us going is
just
that perseverance and i'm i'm the one
where i can get
a house fever so i'm looking at all
those homes that are out there and
saying oh we could move into this house
that's upgraded
yeah let's open it up let's finish this
one first
then she slaps me across the head and
brings me back down to earth
there you go i like it very good you
guys
very very well done so proud of you it's
absolutely amazing so what do you tell
people the secret is to getting out of
debt you but how old are you
uh 33 32 and you paid for house yes
you're so weird that's amazing what do
you tell people the secret to that is
i would say perseverance because
especially when you're paying off your
house it's not a one-year
run and just
continually reminding each other of what
your goal is and why you're doing it
and then we also would tune in to the
radio show
especially if we were feeling a little
bit an
itch to do something else to upgrade to
a different house we're like no
let's listen to the other debt free
screams and the other
things and that gives a lot of
encouragement too to keep going
that's awesome and a written plan yeah
and being on the same page with your
spouse
we had a written plan and a plan of how
we were going to
get this done uh five years ago and
just kept persevering through it and
we're on the same page together and so
when you have all four wheels of the
truck going the same direction then you
can make progress
that's good it's absolutely powerful
well done you guys
and you brought the kiddos with you what
are their ages and names
we have corey come on
turn around and then we have kara ray
corey just turned
five and kara is going to turn three
next week all right
very fun good times good looking hat
there
that's right excellent job all right
good good well we've got a copy of the
legacy journey for you give you yet
another book
uh that's the next chapter in your story
you've changed your whole family tree
very well done a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away
and use that for your uh pay it forward
moment
so andrew nikki cory and cara from grand
rapids michigan 165
000 paid off seven years 11 months
making 90 to 115
house and everything they're not even 35
years old
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one we're
dead
[Applause]
wow that's fun that is so cool
that is so fun the house everything and
those little girls like
like they said they're never going to
remember the sacrifices they go on
whatever vacation they want to now
rachel was born the year we filed
bankruptcy and they do not have memories
uh
denise was a toddler they do not have
memories of that they do not have
memories of the stuff that we went
through
because by the time they were old enough
to start actually having a memory
right we were already i have already
been applying these principles for years
right
right
and we were turning it around ourselves
and so it you know
i think there's a drama queen that lives
inside of all of us so we go
how were there children you're going to
damage their little side
no you're not it's like you always say
live like no one else so later you can
live and give like no one else and it's
we've even talked about this in the
theme of the time management doing the
right things at the right time
do the right things at the right time
live like no one else later you can live
and give like no one else
that's how it works christy wright
ramsey personality my co-host today
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five our question of the day
comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you'll get free samples
free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more always use
the promo code ramsey
to get the best possible deal today's
question comes from
jacqueline in washington i'm a 15 year
old high school student running a
non-profit organization
we teach online classes to younger
students and host events like guest
speakers and
writing competitions our organization
was founded during quarantine last year
so our online classes really took off
and we've raised over 7 500
with things opening up around the
country we've been struggling to find
students to sign up for our online
classes
do you have any recommendations on how
to reach a wider audience or
market that's interesting because you
know what we did last year with covet
dave is we just all
adapted and pivoted and adapted and
pivoted and brainstormed and got
creative and thought outside the box and
all that and it sounds like that's what
she has to do again because if her main
audience space was there because
of covet and quarantine having to do
online classes
it's time to adapt again and figure out
why
would someone come to an online class
now and if not what does it look like to
maybe do something in person
if if that's what the audience is
wanting so it's one of those things
where we're constantly
adapting and iterating and meeting the
needs of our market
even as the environment or the markets
needs change you know
if you're using guest speakers it always
do the subject they're covering and
are you putting uh you know are you
putting the right lure
on the end of the fishing line um in
order to attract
what you're wanting to attract there and
that's going to affect it as well
so uh you know and here's the thing you
are
not far out of your own focus group
meaning that you're
you think a lot like your customers
think probably
and so you probably think about what
would you go to and why would you do it
and um you're not going to be far off on
that now when i started this show that
was the case because i was in my
uh early 30s and a lot of the people we
were talking to
were in the early 30s so i could i could
i knew what my customer was thinking
because i was the same person as my
customer
nowadays i'm not yeah you know and so uh
nowadays i'm talking to people in their
20s and 30s and i'm 60. so it's a
different thing but
she has the advantage of uh being in
and you know in the same headspace and
you can kind of go well why would i do
that
right and you can always ask i think
sometimes as business owners we feel
like we have to be psychic
and just know what our audience wants
and it's like embarrassing somehow to
ask them what they want you can just ask
like if you're not signing up for these
online classes
why aren't you signing up anymore what
are we missing what do you need
what do you want more of or less of just
ask them sometimes it can be a simple
email or survey that does that
cherry is in boston hi cheru how are you
hey dave and christy so pumped to talk
to you guys
youtube appreciate you taking the call
absolutely how can i
yeah dave like over the last two years i
can think of one single day where i've
like not watched you on youtube
or heard you on you know on the podcast
wow
um yeah but uh i guess i'm 28 years old
i moved to the us from india when i was
21 to go to grad school
i landed in the country with a hundred
dollars and um
you know during those grad school days
had a bunch of days where i was like
hungry and homeless
uh but i was just like really grateful
and excited to be in america
um but yeah when i finished up grad
school i had a
fifty six thousand dollar student loan
and an eighteen thousand dollar car loan
uh fast forward today um i'm debt free
i have a six month emergency fund and um
i have uh forty one thousand dollars in
my roth and my 401k
impressive well done
thank you thank you and uh at my current
job i'm making
around 70 to 72 000 and just yesterday i
got
offered a job in new york however i'm
going to make about 140 000
oh wow i love it
good for you thank you thank you and uh
i think my question is uh just in terms
of like how do i
really like roll over my retirement
accounts and also what would be the wise
thing to do
since my income is taken almost to jump
to you know twice of what it currently
is
wow well you never take you you always
take your old 401k with you but you
never take it to the new job
you always just take it as an ira
rollover get with a smart vester pro
uh at ram at ramseysolutions.com and
they'll help you uh
select some mutual funds and roll the
old 401k into it of course you'll start
a new one at the new place
um that's a new no-brainer as far as
that part goes and the second part of
your question was what again
oh what to do with all the money thing
be do with you know the jumping income
huh well you're also going to have a
jumping uh
cost of living cost of living thank you
very much
i was thinking the same thing you
definitely are your income's going up
but your cost of living is i'm guessing
i mean boston's not cheap
but new york is just crazy so so just
take into account that your budget's
going to change as well your expenses
are going to change as well your
um yeah just the cost of all the normal
things you do will go up so you will
need that and part of that is reflected
in that income
as well you're you say new york you're
working in manhattan right
yes yes but i'll probably live in new
jersey yeah yeah i got it but i mean
you're yeah
you're you know you're moving into one
of the more expensive markets in the
world
as far as cost living goes and rent and
everything
and so um uh uh but that's not that's
not gonna eat up all the difference you
still this is still a wonderful decision
and really you're going the right
direction
um as far as extra money goes we're
gonna walk the baby steps man i mean
you're out of debt
you build your emergency fund and uh you
start saving towards buying a home
someday
and it may take you a little while and
of course you're putting 15
of your income to a way towards
retirement and uh
you know but you've come so far i mean
you hit the docks with 100 bucks and you
go from there to here this is absolutely
amazing amazing
so proud of you very very well done
jonathan is in
anchorage hey jonathan how are you i'm
doing well how are you
better than i deserve how can i help all
right so
me and my wife just graduated back in
may and then we got married at the end
of may
we both graduated with our
undergraduates she's wanting to go to
uh thank you physical therapy school but
she's going to be taking a gap year so
we can so she can work and save up a
little bit of money
um so my question is uh should we be
paying off our student loans which is
about
35 000 right now or should we be saving
as much as we can in this next year and
trying cash flow
as much as her master's degree as we can
i don't think she'll do this master's
degree right now
okay because you said i want to try
to cash flow it which means let me tell
you what that means it means you're not
going to do it
yeah no we would probably be able to do
the first year
the second third you need to pay cash
for this or you don't need to do it
if you put your debt on hot if you put
your debt repayment on hold and you
spend all this time piling up cash
and you guys work like maniacs uh
and you can pay cash then for her move
you don't have all the cash up front but
you have to wait
uh see a way that you can cash flow this
and you start you change your statement
to we are going
to cash flow this not we're going to try
when you change that statement then
she's ready to go to school and if that
means a two gap year
that's cool but if it means one and you
guys work like
maniacs and put in the thousand hours
then that's cool
but um you know let me tell you that
pt's uh it's a good it's a good field to
be in
but it's not worth going into debt to do
it's so interesting how we make
decisions differently if you take
one of those options off the table if
you take debt off the table
you get creative and you find a way to
make it work to pay for this school in
cash
debt-free find any other other are there
internships scholarships work programs
anything to help fund it
but if debt is on the table and this is
true for undergrad graduate school
anytime if debt is on the table
you will take it because it's easy
because it's available
because working your tail off is hard
because researching scholarships is
difficult
if it's an option on the table you will
take it it has to be off the table it
has to be completely taken off the table
as an option
and then you can actually think of how
you're going to do this debt-free
without
loans maybe she goes to work for a firm
that does pt right
right and maybe they pay for it exactly
yeah there's maybe there's there's a lot
of ways
you can get creative it's a lot of work
to pull this off but i'm going to try
it translates i'm not going to yeah so
that you you need to reset your minds on
this jonathan because you're going back
she's going to make a mess
and i know you think i'm some kind of
mean old dream killer or something but
what i'm trying to do is kill your dad
gum nightmare and have you call me back
four years ago a little mess
don't do that don't don't go get
yourself in a mess just
avoid it right now that puts this hour
of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us christy wright ramsey personality
number one best-selling
author is my co-host today her brand new
book is
on pre-order we just launched it last
week it is selling at a brisk pace
apparently it's going to be another
number one for her it's called take back
your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance you can get it along
with the uh
audiobook and the e-book all of it comes
out in september but if you buy it now
we throw in
all these goodies and more lots of
goodies goodies goody goodies everywhere
so your pre-order it helps christy with
the marketing
because we get a bunch of pre-sales it
helps get on the best seller list and
that kind of stuff
and in return we help you because we
give you all kinds of stuff we always do
that with a pre-launch on a book
and uh to try to get to entice a bunch
of you to get in
and it's it's a win-win so you get a
bunch of goodies that you know like 150
200
worth of stuff when you buy the book
that you wouldn't get if you wait until
the book comes out
and what do we get we get a pre-order so
it's a fair trade we like the trade
and uh everybody wins here so check it
out ramsey solutions.com
exciting times to uh have a guilt-free
guide
to life balance because people are back
out of balance again yeah and it's
amazing to hear how this message is
resonating you know i've been talking
about this for
a long time but gosh it is such a pain
point it's not just a female issue
men women business owners work in the
workplace have kids don't have kids we
all have this sense
that things are out of balance we
struggle to manage all the things
and and i think sometimes we ask the
wrong question so i really wanted to dig
into the issue behind the issue
in this book which is why the tagline is
about the guilt-free guide
and uh and it's been really cool dave to
see how how it's resonating talking
about the the
the root problem of our feeling with
this topic and then fixing it there
you know i was thinking about this
somebody was interviewing me in the last
week or so
it might have been you um about this
topic we've done so much around this
topic
especially lately and you and i have
discussed this topic off and on for five
years
or more uh you doing the talk at entre
leadership on on life balance was always
a big hit
and uh my disgust with the general
the general uh this idea that
everybody's going to be balanced and
everybody's going to have everything
just right and
i like to pick topics that you hate it's
a specialty
of america i mean shut up and go get
your work done but you know
and on that note our new book on life
balance everyone
yeah so i mean that's that's the thing
so as i was thinking about though
really when you do get your life balance
when you do take back your time
there is a um
there's a little bit of that uh i'm sick
and tired of being sick and tired i've
had it
yeah where you go okay i am so tired
of being pulled in 43 000 directions
that i'm gonna develop a new word when
people ask me to do something and it's
called
no yeah yeah and you know that happened
to me
now i've gotten really good you're so
good at it
no i can say no nope not coming you
don't even feel a little bit bad about
it
i used to i used to i really i did i
used to feel bad for a minute and i
don't feel bad
even for a nanosecond now because it's
just no i'm not the messiah
it's his job jesus job is to be god i'm
not him and i can't be everywhere do
everything
and just because you get mad at me
because i can't come do your thing over
there
i'm sorry no no no no no
no i need to be at home with sharon
ramsey and
rufus the shih tzu no no you know
you know what's interesting about this
topic too and this is what i found after
you know a decade of speaking on this
is we don't define what life balance
means or what
you know we feel like we need it but we
don't even know what it is we don't know
what it is but we know we don't have it
yeah and so there's this sense this
haunting sense that we're always failing
so no matter
what you do what you say yes to or no to
or where you spend your time
you somehow still end up at the same
place feeling bad
about how you spend your time and that's
the reason that i think this is not just
a calendar issue
i think there's deeper issues that we
have to talk about when we when we look
at
how we approach our calendar saying no
is certainly a piece of it there's also
uh this pressure to do everything for an
equal amount of time
and i've talked about that and i
remember hearing you say five or six
years ago
it's a great line it's the it's the line
really almost is one of the thesis lines
of the books
book is uh you're going to disappoint
someone so just decide to disappoint the
right people
yeah you know i i if if i've never met
you
and you live in xyz and you want me to
do abc
and you're disappointed uh versus my
uh daughter's disappoint because i
missed her prom pictures because i was
over doing your stupid thing yeah
uh i just disappoint the wrong people
yeah you're gonna disappoint somebody so
go ahead just decide who it is
and that's when i got real good at no
well and so often i think we focus on
the no and then we feel bad about the no
but what if you shifted that and it's
not about the no it's about what that no
allows you to say yes to i'm going to
say yes to the prom yes to my kids
yes to whatever's in front of me i mean
dave one of the things i've noticed in
my life and
so many women i work with struggle with
no matter where we are
we're focused on where we're not so
we're at work we're worried about the
kids we're at home we're thinking about
working on email
if you live your whole life this way of
course you feel guilty
because you're always focused on where
you're you're not so if you're on
vacation and you're spending your time
in the lounge chair planning the next
vacation does that count
[Laughter]
just vacation to vacation done i have
done that like this is great i need more
of this in my life i need more time to
plan
more vacations but yeah i sit here and
book the next one while i'm sitting here
it's interesting it's not a productivity
book it's a it's about balance and so
when we address the right issue you get
the right results
take back your time the guilt free guide
the life balance by christie wright you
can get it
at ramseysolutions.com in the store
along with all the goodies
edwin is in wilkes bar pennsylvania hi
edwin how are you
hi guys thank you so much for taking my
call today i appreciate that
our pleasure how can we help him yeah so
i'm i'm a newer listener not really
i've been listening for a few months now
i'm just on youtube
i enjoy the show so much um me
personally
in my life um i'm not on a bad pace or
anything i have no debt i'm 22 years old
um right now i've just been focusing on
saving getting my income higher
um but for me personally my problem is
that
you know everyone around me in my life
struggles with money
um i try to you know give the most
advice that i could to everyone
um just try to get them on a better page
especially with uh with the cars i tell
them all the time sell their cars
because they all have you know
cars that they can't afford um who are
you telling to sell their car when
you're 22.
um my brother's my sister
um they love their cars yeah yeah they
thought you were crazy yeah okay i
figured yeah
i just i just want to know how could i
motivate it's really just my family you
know because
money has always been a struggle um
throughout our whole lives for all of us
um
and i'm on a page where i don't really
struggle with money anymore i live so
crudely
hey edwin edwin let me tell you you
can't be responsible for other people
you take care of you set a good example
they'll start asking what you're doing
different
i appreciate your heart but but you
can't change their mind and you can't
change their behavior
i want you i want you to continue to
want your family to do better but quit
telling them
we're tell them what to do they're not
going to do it they're only going to do
it after you
go make a success of yourself and then
they want to be like you
so go be who you want to be and that is
the best way to get them on board
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save
50 off your first month pure talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
when it comes to making big money or big
life moves
like buying a home or getting married or
having a baby it's likely the last thing
on your mind to make sure you have the
right insurance
i understand that but big changes can be
overwhelming
but i'll tell you what if you have a
problem and you didn't take care of the
insurance adjustment
to adjusting to the new life situation
bad idea you buy a house you don't put
fire insurance on it burns two weeks
later it's a bad idea
don't care if you were overwhelmed
moving or not you should have gotten
dead come insurance in place
uh yeah you kick your own butt right you
know what i'm saying so
if not having the time or energy is
what's keeping you from getting the
right coverage with your insurance then
work with an endorsed local provider an
elp
insurance agent they're independent
agents they will shop all the coverages
get you the best price among a bunch of
different companies and they do it all
free of charge
and you save money and you get the best
coverage
independent agent shops all around and
they do it all for free
text insurance to 33 789 to get
connected
with an elp and let a pro help you find
the coverage that fits your life at the
best price
text insurance 233
789 so christy if you're
22 or you're 42
and you get really really enthused about
a new thing
it is human nature to want people that
you're doing something that's working
for you you're winning because you got
this thing whatever it is and um
then you want other people to win you
want other people to experience the
success that you've had
it is natural to want to tell your
brother to sell his car yeah
to tell your mom and dad to get their
act together you know
our whole family's always been bad with
money and i found a guy who's good with
money no matter if you're 22 or 42.
the problem is people don't care
that you're excited and it's i mean it's
like
uh if you lose a bunch of weight and you
run around telling everybody they have
to do what you did
or you whatever i mean i'm glad you lost
a bunch of weight i lost 37 pounds this
year so i needed to i got
fat during coping and so uh but i
haven't run around made everybody else
do it
you know and now some people ask how i
did it and what i did and i've shared
that with them then
but i didn't go up to them and go i'm
looking at you and i'm thinking you need
to lose some weight
i didn't do that you know that's kind of
unappealing it
is and it's interesting because i think
everybody regardless of your personality
style
is resistant to someone telling them
what to do
on an unsolicited advice someone just
coming up to them saying hey you need to
sell your cart regardless of if your
family members
the difference is like you described if
someone shows an interest
hey how'd you do that hey how'd you pay
off all your debt hey how'd you lose all
that weight
when they initiate because they're
interested because they've seen your
example
they are so much more receptive to the
path the plan the principles
then someone just uninvited comes up to
them tells us hey you're doing it wrong
here's what you need to do different
the natural inclination is to dig your
heels and go whoa
whoa whoa whoa you don't know me it's
not your business you know i missed the
part where i asked
regardless of who you are that's that's
a in the human nature to resist that so
how you do it
it matters as much as what you do and so
uh
setting that example and letting people
come to you and then being open to say
hey here's what i did
here's what worked for me this can work
for you too yeah and what you can do is
just start asking some questions
uh you can start telling your story tell
your story
and you know we can use the weight loss
example we can use the money example you
can go
hey man i just paid off twenty two
thousand dollars in debt
and people are gonna go oh wow that's
kinda cool man
yeah how did you do that yeah and well
you asked
that's right so you don't ask that's
right you know now you're going to get
the whole
the whole thing is to trick them into
asking there you go
tell your story and then they invite you
into their story well then you've earned
a right to you've earned a right to be
heard
and i think that makes a big difference
versus just going around pointing a
finger casting blame no one responds
well to that
but when you set an example through your
life when you talk about what what's
working for you
you've earned the right to give that
advice because you've actually lived it
hey watch my debt free scream on youtube
you know hey look here that's what i did
man or you could just go
you know i was really scared and i
didn't know what to do
man i got on this budget and just being
on a plan
i feel like i got a raise and again all
you're doing is telling your story
and you keep telling your story until
they ask
how'd you do that that's right and if
they never ask you can't say
that's why you should do this too
because you get as soon as you cross
that line
if they if they don't invite you to the
party you are an uninvited guest
at the party that's stinky
that's right nobody likes that that's
rude nobody wants to be the uninvited
guest and so
and it's the worst is when you try
to do this with your parents because you
have the powdered butt syndrome once
someone has powdered your butt they
don't want your opinion
on money or sex and so i i you know i
i have very accomplished and successful
children i do not need their opinion
unless i ask that's right but you know
my son daniel ramsey and i were talking
about a business thing the other day he
was showing me this thing he's redoing
in one
area of the company and it was
impressive and he wasn't telling me what
i should do
that wouldn't work no right but he was
what he was he was
inviting me and i i did i stepped right
into it
i i said that's pretty cool how are you
doing that
and then he gets to tell me instead of
coming in going we need to change this
around here and you don't know what
you're doing and i'm like hey dude
you weren't even as gleam in your
mother's eye when i started this thing
so you need to shut up
but instead he uh oh my gosh you know he
he
you gotta be strategic he did he was
taught by a pro he completely suckered
me in
but that's that's it you tell your story
and that invites people to come in and
and you know that's true
of your faith you want to talk about
your jesus
you're you know that's the most rude
offensive thing in the world it's a bust
up in somebody's face talking about
jesus
and you don't even have to know them and
they don't care what you think about
jesus
instead you start talking about what god
did for you
what was your story that's right this is
what happened to me
i was here and now i'm here i was there
and here i'm in a different place now
and you can you can tell your story all
day and
very few people are offended by you
telling your own story you know i um i
answer questions at the end of the
christy wright show and i got a question
i draw questions out of a fishbowl so i
don't know what's in the what's in the
bowl
and several weeks ago i drew a question
out and the question was
why did you choose jesus over other
religions that's how it was worded
and dave i was so caught off guard
because normally it's like how do i
balance it all right like it's like
these practical questions
i was so caught off guard but i just in
that moment just told my testimony and
it was that exact moment of going
i've been invited to share what this is
to me
and what how my life has been
transformed by this jesus i talk about
and because i was asked i was able to
to to share that in a different way but
you're right it's it's
it's setting the example where people
want to ask what's different about you
what's different about you yeah that's
why when somebody knocks on your door
and forces a book in your face
that doesn't work you know and uh i mean
i saw something the other day on social
media it's like
if one more person gives me the dave
ramsey book i'm going to kill him
i appreciate people buying my books but
i kind of agree yeah you know an
unsolicited give me a diet book what are
you saying
you know what's your point okay
unsolicited give me a dave book what are
you saying you say i'm a doofus
yeah you probably are but you know you
just you just insulted somebody with you
now take back your time book might not
be quite as bad
it might not be quite i always give you
a hard time because when someone gives
someone your book it says you have a
problem when someone gives you one of my
books like business boutique it's like i
believe in you
i need to write a believe in you book
there you go i need it i don't know you
got your brand very on point with what
you're doing here dave
what are you saying the brand's
offensive what are you saying christy
we all know our strengths david we all
know where streets we're supposed to be
sitting oh my god
that is if you want to convince someone
particularly people you love
we tend the closer we are to them the
the the
tackier we tend to be yeah we violate
even just basic persuasion technique
you know we just go because it's my
brother i can say anything i want
yeah and you you always talk about this
in motivation similar to the topic of
balance but
you know you get asked this all the time
through entre leadership how do i
motivate my team and you say you don't
you hire motivated people he even asks
how do i motivate my family you can't
motivate other people you really can't
no but what you can do is put
inspiration in front of them yes
and they may hook their wagon to it yeah
and you my son
are the inspiration yep that's it that's
the deal
so tell your story even if you don't the
story doesn't have to be over
you could be just starting the story but
tell your story don't wag your finger at
them
that's your only shot folks this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
wright ramsey personality is my co-host
today
errol and rachelle are with us from
wilmington
delaware and on the phone to do a
debt-free scream what's up
guys hey hello hello
i love it how much have you paid off 32
000 cool how long did this take
uh it took about 15 months okay and your
range of income during that time
uh we started off around 85 000 and then
got right up to 99
000 at the end cool like a hundred grand
very good yeah so close
what do you guys what do you guys do for
a living so
i work in uh tech at microsoft and
side business photography cool and i'm a
high school math teacher
fun fun very good very good what kind of
debt was this
oh it was uh
wedding debt uh loan debt credit card
debt
you you name it okay
wow good for you guys so what happened
what started the journey
so really it was it was all about
like you know i came in to our marriage
with debt
and my wife she didn't make me feel
bad about having that debt she real she
said you know we're one we're together
in this
this is our debt i try to make it seem
more individualized
but um with that we
tackled it it was a hard journey
because i couldn't see the end of the
road but
through through uh perseverance and
then trial and error and just following
that path
um we did it okay who started this whole
thing rachelle
oh yes i thought i heard that yeah okay
all right rachelle what'd you do what
happened um i heard
about you back in grad school
i wasn't in debt yet but i was about to
be
um in order to get to grad school and so
i immediately started getting some
financial
education and i heard about you and so i
went through your program in grad school
and had paid off my debt by time i was
25
and then we got married and i said well
i know it works we can do this
to which harold said yes ma'am
that this can be real it can be can be
done yeah
well i'm so proud of you guys that's
awesome who are your biggest
cheerleaders
oh my i know my wife was
just just keep pushing me and pushing me
and pushing me
all right what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is you guys
paid off 32 000 in 15 months
follow the plan follow the plan
i'm like the spender and i'm like all
right this plan works i got to follow
this plan
how does it feel now that you get to
keep all your money you're not paying it
backwards and
and paying at all these debts you it
must feel like you've got all this money
if it feels good it feels good um
it's still a temptation because it's
like oh there's an offer and it's like
you can save
just by going back into debt and i'm
like no no no
no no no no that that i don't ever want
to be there ever again
yeah it's too much trouble to get out
never go back yes it is
a way to go you guys very very proud of
you great job
so it feels awesome now huh yeah i said
we don't want to be
i tell him we're going to get out of
debt before we start a family and so
we got out of debt and now we're
sticking a baby
that's awesome congratulations that's
the most important part of the whole
call right there
that is so great congratulations you
guys are so proud of you
well we've got a copy of the legacy
journey because you've changed the
legacy for this baby by changing the way
you've handled money and
getting yourself out of debt so proud of
you and we also got a copy of the total
money makeover
uh and uh we'll send that up to you you
can give that away to someone
and pay it forward and hopefully you can
do that in a way that they want to read
it and
good stuff you know what i'm going to
throw in one more kelly let's send them
smart money smart kids the book that
rachel and i did on how to teach your
kids
how to handle money awesome and we'll
make that a gift for the new baby that's
on the way
so good thank you you guys are
incredible
very very well done so proud of you good
job
all right it's errol and rachel in
wilmington delaware
32 000 paid off in 15 months making
85-99
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how it is done baby
wow that's awesome that's so cool what
a what a great year they've had i know
it's so exciting
expecting a baby and knowing you're
you're starting that journey debt-free i
mean that's just awesome
one less thing to worry about it's not
mandatory but it sure is gives you a lot
of peace that's right it sure does
excellent keith is with us keith's in
orlando hi keith how are you
hi dave christie honored to speak with
you guys you too what's
so i find up in a weird position i've
been following the baby steps
and i've completed one two three and
four uh step five doesn't really apply
to me right now i'm single
not married uh no kids no plan for kids
and some years
and i have about twenty thousand dollars
extra in my savings account
while i'm working on step six paying off
my mortgage
um this is separate from my uh emergency
fund
and i wanna do either one of three
things with it this is where i'd like
your guidance
um would you like some options
okay so option one would be to throw it
all directly into my mortgage
um because i closed my house with only
five percent down on the third year
fixed
i know that's against your wishes i did
this before as a ramsay listener
okay um so doing that and having a
healthy appraised
option option two is uh just invest it
put in a good mutual fund money market
account
have it grow that way or um option three
is kind of the
careless one but potentially just to
enjoy some of it because i've been
debt-free for a long time without the
mortgage what do you make of your drive
up pretty old
my base value is 85 but with commissions
last year was 183
this year i'm expecting about 150 000.
for you and what are you driving
i drive a 2007 fj cruiser okay
what do you think christy um you know i
always go to this and this is the
opposite of what you always say but i'm
always like
i like dividing it up i'm like you can
you can play with a little bit of money
put some on your mortgage
invest some like i'm like i like just
kind of spreading it out when you've got
extra not obviously like when you got
you know when you're on a specific step
but
i don't know i would i would do no
investing
above 15 of your income anything that
you would have invested i would put
towards your mortgage i would split it
between
some enjoyment i think you need to
upgrade your car
and um when you're making 150 000 a year
you're driving a freaking hooptie
so i think you need i think you need to
move up about 10 grand in car
and uh if it were me now so here's the
thing when you're in baby steps four
five and six
you are not gazelle intense you are
instead
intentional and so what you're doing is
you're saying i'm going to be very
intentional with my dollars i'm going to
enjoy some i'm going to give some
i'm going to be investing my 15 percent
and the rest of it i'm going to throw on
a mortgage
and that's my intentionality and i i
think your past due to move up in car
and so uh if i woke up in your shoes i'd
probably spend about 10 grand on a car
and probably throw about 10 grand at the
mortgage
but i i don't want to tell you ever to
do any investing beyond 15
until your mortgage is paid off so i'm
always going to throw it at the mortgage
or add some enjoyment but i think you've
got some things in your life that have
been put on hold back when you were in
baby steps one two and three and they
should have been on hold then
but now that you're at this stage you
should be intentional
not necessarily as intense does that
make sense
correct it does yeah one simple thing
awesome
very quick if i would if i were to throw
this 20 000
at my mortgage it would put me at uh
over 20 equity i could have the house
free to praise and it would get rid of
my pmi yeah
that's very tempting then but but then
you don't get a car
so i don't know you decide which one you
want to do and when you want to do it
all i care is you're doing it on purpose
that's the intentional part
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five zack is with us in houston
hi zach how are you i'm doing fine
how are y'all today better than we
deserve what's up
awesome i got a question for both of
y'all i am looking for advice
so it is solicited he's been listening
it was a great segment by the way um for
my living situation
i am in between either buying a home or
getting an apartment
um with this housing market the way it
is i don't know if i should jump on the
bandwagon and try to outbid somebody
like others i've seen been doing
or if i should just wait till it cools
off and
go from there how much do you have saved
i have 65 000 saved in a
an account then i also have
140 in investments
thanks to the smartvestor pro program so
thank you dave and your team
cool the investments are retirement
accounts like roth and so on
uh yes mutual funds some retirement
stuff i rolled into an ira
but it's all all in some kind of a
retirement or some of it in just
miscellaneous mutual funds
uh both mostly in mutual funds
okay i'm gonna try one more time because
i'm still confused it should all be
in mutual funds but okay is is it not in
roth and iras of some kind
i'm sorry it is raw okay all of that it
should be i was thinking it was okay
so you don't have anything that you can
cash out of investments
without retirement penalties right
incorrect i have about 50 of that that i
put
cash towards that i could pull out
whenever i wanted
okay that's not in a roth ira or not in
an ira of any kind
okay is that what you're saying i
believe so yes okay then i would use
that 50 and i would use this 65
together for your down payment i don't
put as much down on this house that does
not cash out retirement to put down
now okay here's the thing and you're out
of debt and you have your emergency fund
right
the only debt i have is about 17 000
towards a truck
we have to pay that off before we can
have this discussion okay
so when you get off the phone go pay
that off okay um then then we're going
to take the
uh what's remaining with your you're
about 100 000 roughly to
to put down the house then between the
50 and the 50
65 minus 17. and you've got an emergency
fund
the 65 includes that emergency oh my
gosh so we don't have that either okay
all right so we got to break that out so
your your three to six months of
expenses is set aside
and you've got 48 000 of the 65 left
because we just paid your truck off
and you you finish your emergency
because we don't buy we do not recommend
buying a house until you're debt-free
and have the emergency fund so that's
where we're trying to get you to
okay which you can be there with what
you have you just need to think about it
differently and allocate it differently
and not use that towards your down
payment is what we're saying
exactly and so let's just say we put 20
000 bucks in the
an emergency fund just for the fun of it
okay okay so out of 65 minus 17
minus 20 that's going to leave you 28
there
50 in investments that's not in
retirement funds of any kind
would be 78 that you've got for a down
payment on a house with a fully funded
emergency fund and no truck payment
you with me yes sir that's where we
would take you to
and then if you want to go buy a house
that's fine
but what you want to avoid is uh the
land of stupid and crazy
and most of what's going on out there
right now is the land of stupid and
crazy
so you just want to go looking at houses
and if you can buy one
and not feel like you were a nut job
when you bought it
then then go ahead and buy it right
there's nothing to say you can't
buy in this market but what you don't
want to do is get caught up in
this thing where you're paying 150 000
more for a house than it's worth
because a whole bunch of goobs lined up
on the sidewalk and at an auction
right okay so you know you go make an
offer on a house and if you don't get it
that's fine and
you just don't feel the pressure and you
don't get the house fever
and you wander around and kind of take
your time and
if you can sneak up on one fine or if
you get frustrated with the whole
process and want to just wait
that's okay too but you there's just
don't what you're saying is
i don't want to participate in crazy and
i'm agreeing with you
so but that doesn't mean you can't find
somebody to sell a house
in in houston texas it's possible and
the market has cooled
in the last 30 days over what it was in
most markets it was just
about 30 days ago was probably the apex
and uh
it was the first time in since we've
kept records in the real estate world
that that are accessible that over half
of the houses that sold sold for
more than asking price and that was 60
days ago
and it's gone down since then and so
it's just
it's not it's still crazy still crazy
but it's not anywhere near as crazy as
two months ago i had a question dave for
all the people listening right now that
are in that position where they're
either buying their
i guess mostly probably buying their
first home maybe buying you know a
different house or moving
how do you discern am i being a nut job
or not
because i think a lot of people
especially someone you know that
like zach that he's buying his first how
much is how what is reasonable what is
too much because we've talked before
about you know the demand
dictates the price and so someone's
willing to pay it you know this is the
new value this is the new price point
if someone's listing right now and they
want to buy a house how do they discern
okay this is this is a normal
competitive good
thing to offer and this is now getting
into the land of crazy do you have any
type of parameters to help people
discern that
because this is so scary for a lot of
people right now
well i mean okay number one anytime
you're doing something new buying a
house you've never bought before it's
gonna feel a little scary sure
whatever you do yeah that's not the kind
of scary i'm talking about
but i think most of us know when we're
out of control in a frenzied
buying mode you know it's almost like a
manic thing
like a manic depressive like a bipolar
thing and we all have that little thing
i mean i know when i have bought stuff
when there was nothing going to keep me
from buying it i was like an addict
you know what i mean and i think if you
got that if you're in that gear
you know you need to stop and back away
and that's
that it may not even be the price it may
just be a spiritual thing that you're
not supposed to do that right now
because if you're getting in that manic
gear in that gear where nothing can keep
me from
from my housing fix like you're a
freaking addict or something you got
house fever yeah
and and and that's when these people are
going that's when they're going to wake
up with regret on the back of their
tongue
you know they're going to wake up with a
financial hangover
having bought the house and it's not
necessarily oh you paid 22 percent more
there's not a formula okay but you you
kind of know
that you're out of control you know i
mean i can't even remember
going in freaking costco and there's too
much stuff in the buggy yeah you know
i'm just
out of control yeah and and it it it's
your trip to gear there it's not just
okay this is a
systematic methodical reasonable
wise purchase so you're saying more
check in with yourself
it's less about the house and the price
than it is like what's going on
because i don't think there is a formula
on the house or the price yeah i mean
obviously if you go way up over
the value of the asking price and any
comps in the area
and you're going to pay 40 more than
it's ever appraised for before you're
probably in the stupid land i mean oh
and how can you even be excited about
that because
you're just the one that paid more like
it's like it's like yeah you got it but
you're also just
the highest bidder i know it usually has
to do with they're moving from a very
expensive market to a less expensive
market so they
perceive value right there that's not
there
okay like california people coming to
nashville i mean we see that a ton yeah
you move out of uh
you know you move out of silicon valley
and you move to abilene texas my god you
can buy half the town yeah with when you
sold your house
you know and so but that doesn't mean
you should right
that doesn't mean it's a good buy
doesn't mean you're not going to be able
to resell it
right after you do that because but the
real estate prices are just so
different that it emotionally just lets
you get out of control
yeah and so you've got to use just some
methodical
okay here's what the house appraises for
with comps
the market's really hot so it's probably
worth a little bit more than that
uh really i mean it really might
appraise because there's a heat on the
thing
supply and demand but it's not worth 34
percent more yeah
gotcha i mean you know we're not gonna
take a 500 000 house and pay
750 for it and call that wise right
that that appraised a month ago for 500
right right
right there's we're not in
hyperinflation here yes
it's a range you're kind of looking
that's just your brain going into attic
mode and you've got
house fever yeah and you gotta you gotta
just we all can do it i can do it i can
sense myself doing it
and i have to just go whoa i'm managing
god's money here i got to report to him
how i'm doing this
and he's not going to like my attitude i
got to fix this
this is the ramsey shaft
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write
it down don't worry we list everything
you've heard about during this episode
in the podcast show notes section or
head to the ramsay show.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money christy wright ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host we have launched her new book
for sale last week take
back your time the guilt-free guide
to taking back your life i love it you
got to check it out folks uh and it's i
all the goodies are with it on the
pre-sale the book actually comes out in
september
but if you want the audiobook the e-book
and a bunch of other things worth almost
a couple hundred dollars worth
you can go ahead and pre-order the book
now it helps you because you get all the
stuff it helps us because we get a
pre-sale so all
that's why we like it everybody's
winning here go to ramseysolutions.com
get signed up for that the phone number
here is triple eight eight
two five two shelley is in san francisco
hi shelly how are you
good dave thank you for taking my call
i'm a long time listener and i love the
show
thank you awesome how come um okay
okay so when i was in my 20s i worked
for
the government and i traveled a lot i
was all over the world
i had to move residences many times
and kind of lost track of a couple
things
and i feel like i have i feel like i
remember opening a roth ira
and i just feel like i lost it
and i was thinking about attempting to
try to find it
um and i just don't know the best way to
go about it and if i start calling you
know banks
or institutions but i think it could be
with you know what department do i ask
for
to try to track this down and also could
could
things that i've lost track of been
turned over to the state and like lost
property yeah and if so how long ago how
old
are you i'm 41. this is like 20 years
ago
uh yeah like yes 15 15 20 years ago
yes yeah it could have been turned over
because if an account goes completely
inactive and a bank can't find you
regardless of what kind of account it is
they they will do it so you think this
is probably with a bank
i thought it was with bank of america um
and i did go talk to them
and they tried tracking some stuff down
i don't have like the greatest
confidence that it was you know fully
researched
um but they said they didn't find
anything and nothing was turned over to
the state
um and i've lived in three different
states as well
so it makes it a little more cool the
department of commerce does the
uh the the accounts that are turned over
in each state so you you can contact the
department of commerce in each state
see if your name's on a list there
that's a fairly easy process
um okay and and then you know you've got
bank of america and what are your other
options what are the banks
it was a bank ira you feel like
i feel like it was and it could be with
maybe federal i don't even know if they
do that i have to check them
they don't check into that they do um
and so i yeah and and there may be other
stuff
out there that i lost track of as well
so um i may just do it with everyone i
think it could
possibly be with and check both yeah
they ought to be able to drop your
social into their system
okay uh with written permission from you
and just see if anything shows up an old
checking and old savings an old roth
anything with navy federal or with bank
of america
and uh you you just think you may have
gotten an incompetent do but the branch
at b of a which really wouldn't be that
unusual
yeah yeah well they had some other stuff
messed up in my account as well
which you know looking at it i'm like oh
you know
my name is wrong and things were wrong
about the information that they had on
file with me so
i didn't have the greatest confidence
that it was a thorough search
yeah yeah well you didn't have
confidence in the person who's doing it
what you're telling me so
and again that's not that unusual so
yeah i i think you're on it
i would hit the department of commerce
in the three cities i'd hit navy and i'd
hit
bank of america and if you can think of
a couple more hit hit those
and then and then call it a day and go
uh this is a lesson learned
yeah right you know thank you
i just lost it after that but um
well i would say if you don't get
someone competent at the places that you
call
i mean my go-to is i'll always just call
back i call back the next day get a new
person i'm like hey like i'm like it's
my whole first time calling
and maybe that person might be more
helpful and if that you know give that a
try a few times
hopefully you'll get someone helpful in
the lineup yeah and the same is true the
branch you walk into a branch just go to
a different branch there's another one
and
and you know you can get you know say
hey
i need a little help here yeah and uh uh
the good news maybe federal is probably
pretty responsive because she probably
was
like like she said she was working for
the government at the time and they're
probably going to be of help to her
on more so than b of a that would be my
guess
all right uh bronson's with us in santa
barbara hi bronson how are you
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
so i just got married about
three weeks ago congratulations thank
you so much
i'm very excited for the future and i
just graduated college before that
and i'm about to start law school in
about a month
good and you know being married and
everything
um you know now i have to worry about
you know another person
with money and everything and being in
law school you know i won't be able to
work
you know my nine to five job every day
um
so i'm just looking for ways that i can
capitalize the most
and what you suggest for you know coming
out of law school
i i assume your uh wife is working
yes sir she's a real estate agent okay
so you've got income to work with for
your household right
yes sir okay so exactly what's your
question then
so uh i make about 2
000 a month off of passive income
um and that's going to be basically what
i'm bringing in
uh during law school so what what's the
main way that i
i don't want to just you know keep
putting money in the bank and just
you know have it stored there no there's
not an eye anymore there's a wii
yes sir you got married and so your
household
income is going to be used to pay your
household bills in your law school
yes sir in the 2000 and any commission
she makes on real estate and all of that
i have a full ride scholarship i was
valedictorian in my class
wow good for you yeah got a good
scholarship
um so i won't be paying uh anything
actually for law school
so well then you would work your
household will work the baby steps
and you first save a thousand dollars
and make sure you're debt free
and then begin to build an emergency
fund but this is your whole household
not just your little 2000 it's some
money she's making as well we're all
putting it in one pile and
we're gonna say these are our goals
we're gonna
go ahead get on a budget a real budget
an every dollar budget
bronson you and your wife on a shared
budget that's that's going to be the
tool that helps you do
what you're asking us about on a budget
together
on paper on purpose the money you bring
in the money she brings in
all your expenses that tool is what's
going to help you work that plan
here i'll help you with it we're gonna
give you a wedding gift i'm gonna send
you a copy the total money makeover
and you and your spouse get to read that
as a wedding gift and then it'll get you
rolling
right down the baby steps man that's
what it'll show you how to do
hey congratulations valedictorian
married free law school
yeah come wow awesome this is the ramsey
[Music]
chef
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host
today if you're in debt you're out of
control with your money well i know how
that feels i've been there myself
been a long time ago but i've been there
and i still still remember that feeling
you feel like you're fighting a losing
battle like you're stuck in a
hamster stuck in a wheel am i ever ever
ever gonna get out ahead gosh i wish i
could get ahead of this
well it doesn't have to be like that
when you attack this debt
like your life depends on it you take
back
your life and your paycheck and then you
begin to build the life you really want
and we can show you how to do that we've
shown millions
and millions and millions of families
how to do that
in financial peace university
in this class you learn our proven plan
it's a clear path that's helped millions
of folks pay off their debt
and begin to build wealth a lot of them
become baby steps millionaires
and you know you stick to a budget
you're going gonna get the premium
version of our budgeting tool
world-class
top shelf budgeting tool every dollar
and so you get financial peace
university every dollar and a bunch of
other stuff
on ramsey plus you get your ramsey plus
membership
that's how you get it and you know you
start your free trial of ramsey plus
and your constant battle for your money
well it's
gonna be over you're gonna you're gonna
begin to get control almost immediately
text trial to 33 789
to get a free trial to ramsey plus text
trial two three three seven
eight nine now christy you guys have a
big event coming up for life balance
next wednesday right yes we are talking
about why you get out of balance in the
first place which is important to know
if you're going to fix
this feeling that you have and i just
want to help people get it together
before their life
gets back to crazy in the fall which we
know that august is around the corner
school schedules work schedules all the
things are filling up so we are doing a
free live stream session with me on life
balance wednesday july 28th
seven o'clock central time on youtube
and facebook go to
ramseysolutions.combalance
to get your spot and join me and i'll be
giving you some tips
to get balanced before your life gets
back to busy this fall
wednesday july 28th one week away
seven o'clock free on facebook and on
youtube so just text balance to
or go to ramseysolutions.com balance
rsvp today that simple
christian is with us christian is in
austin texas hi christian how are you
hi dave doing well yourself better than
i deserve how can i help
hi yes i have a question so um my father
just passed away um at the beginning of
the year
oh my goodness and he uh
was kind of in charge in charge of like
all the money
between him and my mom and he didn't
really
um believe in like or understand
investments
so he thought his retirement would be
owning
rental properties and with my dad
passing away
my mom is now
she has to take care of all the rental
properties and
that's like not her only source of
income she has a pension
from a teacher retirement but um
so she's just trying to figure out
whether to sell or keep the houses and
what she should
do and how old and how old is she
she's 58 five eight
how old are you 27
okay and how many houses
did she inherit uh she has two rental
properties and then the house at
her where she lives at okay
uh are they paid off yes they're all
paid off
what are the rental property what are
the rental properties worth
um i would say the two rental properties
would not
to like 350.
each or total a total okay
all right good good where are they
uh they're in el paso taxes okay all
right
well i'm sorry you guys are going
through this it's a hard hard time
for all of you so is your mom
when she talks about these rental
properties is it scary to her
or she just hates them or she just
doesn't know what to do
or what is what is it what comes out of
her when she starts talking about them
uh yeah it's kind of like she's scared
um my brother's helping her with one
with collecting the ranch and
kind of being a property manager at that
for one of them and the other one
is pretty easy but you know whenever an
ac
breaks or uh something breaks at the
house like
she has a point of contact but
she's just trying to figure out
because the house that we that she lives
at she can't really afford it
so she's trying to figure out whether to
get rid of that one
and buy a different one is it paid for
yes it's paid for why can't she not
afford it if it's paid for
um just property taxes are really high
does she not have any income
uh she does but with property taxes
and like all her living expenses
it just covers it
it just covers everything so
how much of the property taxes
uh so for the one where she was that i
think
it came out to like 14 000 for the year
and
sorry i said that does sound high what's
this house worth
uh that one i would say anywhere from
the 200 000 at 300 000 range
so a 300 000 house in el paso texas has
14 000
in property tax yes
that's weird okay um i'm a little
shocked but
uh okay so it's thousand bucks a month
what's her income
uh i think her income is about
three thousand a month so she doesn't
work
no why um
just with ko kovit passing away she's
just waiting for
she's also a teacher so she's going for
school to
get go back in session and start like
substituting
okay you have a temporary problem and
you're coming up with a permanent
solution
her income is not three thousand dollars
a month she's a teacher
her income is seven eight thousand
dollars a month including all these
rents and her teachers income
she can easily afford this house
and selling the house is a permanent
solution for a temporary problem
okay are you saying kristin she does not
want to go back to work is that what
you're really
trying to say yeah she doesn't want to
yeah yeah but i kind of does she but she
doesn't have any money except these two
houses right and the pension
yeah you can't quit work on 350 000 or
58 years old
sorry you don't have enough money so if
you sell these two houses and put money
in investments
and take her pension too she's going to
have a paltry income she's just hurting
and grieving from the loss of your dad
hun
yeah and so what we've got to do is help
her get healed and get past this
she's just feeling vulnerable and weak
and doesn't feel like she's got
the stuff anymore and we just got to
pump her up a little bit and help her
get back into the classroom it'll be
good for healing anyway
and so you know she she needs the income
now if you want to sell the properties
off and put the money in mutual funds
and not have to deal with them that's
fine if you want to hand them to a
property manager
and you and your brother help with the
property manager and the property
manager being the point of contact
collect the stink and rents it'll be
worth the fee to do that
and she'll probably make more money on
these two properties if they're managed
well
than she would on 350 000 in mutual
funds
so that part your dad was actually right
about but they're more hassle
and i don't want her having to be the
point of contact 90 days after she lost
her husband
on a heat and air problem i want you to
put a property manager on these
properties or i want you to sell them
more than two
but i don't think she needs to sell her
house her house is not the problem
and she is gonna have to get back in the
saddle it's gonna be good for her
so man i'm so sorry you guys got a lot
of pain there a lot of stuff you're
working through i feel it with you
but you can do it and i'm glad she's got
you in her corner so square your
shoulders put your arm around your mom
walk her through this you can do it man
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage bran and clinton are
with us hey guys how are you
good good how are you welcome and where
do you guys live
indianapolis indiana all right so good
to have you guys
all the way down here to do a debt-free
scream how much did you pay off so we
paid off 222 thousand
228 dollars oh goodness yeah how long
did this take
about six years just under and your
range of income during that time
about 135 to 195. awesome yeah
what do you guys do for a living i'm a
sergeant on the police department
and i work for a utility provider um
engineering okay cool so i'm gonna guess
with six years and 200 000 bucks you
paid off your house you nailed it
you guys are rock stars absolutely weird
people
yeah this is fabulous yeah well done
well done well done amazing man so
what in the world started you on this
process uh well that's an interesting
story
probably about two years before we got
started uh brent approached me and she
said hey
your cousins are doing this thing called
dave ramsey thing where you pay some
money to uh
go learn about how to handle money and i
was like honey uh
so i'm a police officer and i have the
gift of skepticism and i was like hey
we got to pay money to learn about money
i think that's not right that doesn't
sound right so
about two years later my body approaches
me about it while we're sitting there
in a car at work and he's like hey man
he kind of knew about her situation and
everything was going on he's like hey
you should read this book
it was your book the total money
makeover and so i went home
and i was like hey honey uh we got to do
this like i read the book
and uh i think it was two days i was
like hey we got to do this
and so she was a little bit reluctant at
the time because she was like oh now
that's your idea we gotta
she's like i remember bringing this up i
like that yeah so
i was a reluctant spouse initially and
then she kind of became a reluctant
spouse and we kind of moved past that
initially
or a little bit down the line so yeah
yeah
good job so y'all went all in well did
y'all did y'all have other debt
in addition to the house yes yeah so we
had our uh
about 20 000 in student loans uh we had
28 000 or 29 000 in a truck
uh about the i'm sorry that was our suv
about 36 000 in a truck
and then the rest was a mortgage so in
that same time we uh
cash flowed a bunch of stuff we did
about 30 000 in our house renovations
she got an mba then we had ivf and some
other
surgeries along the way and then some
more vehicle purchases up and down just
between vehicles and whatnot so
a lot of different things happened wow
but you did it
yeah yeah all the way out no house
payment or anything yeah it's awesome
you're so weird
you're so weird how old are you guys i'm
35
and i just turned 33 today today
no house payment what's this house worth
um our neighbors just
uh sold theirs for about 300 so we're
thinking somewhere pretty close to that
yeah yeah so that's got to feel great
it's it does 35 years old but
paid for 33 years old haven't paid for a
house it's all for everything no debt
no payments anywhere no it's weird it's
a really weird feeling but it's awesome
kind of surreal isn't it yeah yeah very
very very
no payments okay what's the story on
this t-shirt
so um our police department we actually
host a lot of the
financial peace classes oh okay yeah so
i've coordinated several of those along
the way
and uh it's just kind of the joke of i'm
not your financial advisor this is not
financial advice do your own due
diligence and so it's basically
i have had people approach me quite a
bit like hey what fun should i be in you
know which exact which funds do you do
and i'm like hey
look i'm not going to give you what i do
but i'll show you kind of the process
the thought process on
what you should be looking at and how to
pick funds if that's something you want
to do or
go find somebody who's going to help you
out how to fish or i'm not going to do
it for you
absolutely good 100 yeah well thanks for
leading at the police department man
yeah it was awesome we've been doing it
for about the last five years there's a
picture
that we sent in that was me and our
lieutenant he's actually getting ready
to retire
oh there it is um yeah so we've uh we've
been doing it for the last five years he
started it up before me and then i
jumped on board to help him out in any
way that i could and
now he's retiring and so i'm getting
ready to take over all right that's
awesome congratulations thank you that's
a lot of fun so what's the secret what's
the secret to getting out of debt and
in y'all's case all the debt even the
house communication
yeah i mean that's a big one yeah you
got to be on the same page uh
obviously we were not initially and uh
it took us a while to get on the same
page
but once we got there then once the
train started
rolling it was so much easier so yeah
definitely say being consistent too
you know keeping your goals in focus and
understanding
why you're doing it that's a big thing i
mean we bought a house
right when he wanted to uh start dave
ramsey
and it was stuck in 1978 so we had a lot
of renovations to do
and i wanted to you know house loan or
credit cards but he's like nope we're
done so we
we took a step back and cash flowed the
whole thing and now it's all paid for
and it's beautiful too updated so yeah
that's great there you go really really
nice well congratulations you guys yeah
thank you very much very very proud of
you and again thank you for
running uh for for running the class at
the police department i
my experience with law enforcement guys
and gals
is that if i can get them talking about
this money thing
that it really big time impacts their
marriage because it gives them a chance
to talk about stuff that otherwise they
might not have talked about that they
needed to
yeah i 100 agree there's a you know
obviously there's a lot of stuff going
on with law enforcement and the stress
and everything else that can happen
and so if you've got something outside
of the work to talk about and kind of
make sure you're talking constantly with
each other it definitely helps a lot
yeah definitely helps
it's a there's a you need that
connectivity and it's it's real easy to
get all walled up with all the stuff you
guys see and do every day and
absolutely uh and the stress and the
weird world that we live in and the
whole thing yeah
i'm sure i'm sure it's like pulling a
thread right like it's like you start
talking about the money and the budget
and actually you get to more layers of
of maybe where you're missing each other
in communication or something some other
stress that that the money was then
kind of highlighting yeah i'm sure brain
would know about that a lot more because
i like to put up those walls quite a bit
and she breaks them down though she does
a good job at it so that's a fairly
normal process yeah
i'm proud of you guys well done thank
you very much well done and again thank
you for leading the class that's very
very powerful
absolutely we've got a copy of the
legacy journey
for you that's the next chapter in your
story you're on your way to being baby
steps millionaires you're going to be
there before you know it
and you guys fit the mold exactly i mean
that's perfect
where you're going to be in five years
is going to be absolutely amazing what
that house will be worth what your funds
will be worth all that
man ding ding yeah it's going to be
great and thank you for ever all the
work that you're doing uh it's really
impacting our police department just
having this program there
definitely can tell us chasing the lives
not only of our police officers but the
civilian people that we have that come
through the class as well that help
it's it's great sure awesome well done
and we got a copy of total money
makeover i'm sure you'll find somebody
to give that to and help out along the
way
and uh so we're so proud of you guys
very well done
thank you very much absolute rock stars
man 35 33 years old paid for
house 222 thousand dollars paid off in
six years
making 135 to 195 clinton and bryn from
indianapolis
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
ready three two one
[Applause]
bring it that's fun that is
very fun you guys very well done
i am amazed as we get into these baby
steps millionaires
how many of them uh you know we found
out the number three
uh career out of the 10 000 that we tr
that we studied uh number one was uh
engineer number two was accountant
number three was teacher
but how often they're married to a
policeman oh wow
i didn't know that there's often uh uh
uh i don't know there's something going
on there and it's um
but they're they're working the baby
steps and they get the millionaire net
worth
and um i'm calling them baby steps
millionaires but that's where they get
to
right and it's happening it's happening
and those guys i mean you look at this
they're making 195 between them uh
you know they probably bumped it up
doing some ot and stuff to get this
thing knocked out but
you know even if they're making 165 you
know whatever right in there
between them uh and they have no house
payment and they're 35 and 33.
the numbers real quickly oh yeah oh yeah
the sky's the limit
yeah it's how fast they're gonna have a
million dollar net worth with their
401ks
and iras and um you know
the value of the paid for home it's
gonna be and it's gonna be classic
because usually the house represents
about a third
[Music]
of the first one to two million dollars
in net worth so
very very very cool fun stuff
i love it i love it i love it this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today matthew 7 16 by the
fruit
by their fruit you will recognize them
do people pick grapes from thorn bushes
or figs
from thistles benjamin israeli said the
legacy of heroes is the memory of a
great name
and the inheritance of a great example
that one will preach open phones here at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five thank
you for joining us america jason
is in phoenix hi jason how are you
hey jason excuse me hi dave and christy
uh thanks for taking my call today
sure what's up uh so my wife and i we're
in baby step three right now and we are
working
on a six-month emergency fund which is
going to be just a little over 41 000
and we're halfway there and expected to
be done
just around march of next year and we
have a couple of changes that we can
make right now that will save us some
money but we're a little bit hesitant to
make those changes until we get that
emergency fund fully funded
and those changes are one we can change
the deductible on our homeowners
insurance from one thousand to five
thousand
and we can drop comp and collision on a
vehicle that's worth about six thousand
and those combined would save us about a
thousand dollars a year but
we're not sure with the increased uh
exposure of changing those if we should
wait until
we're fully funded or make those changes
now i would drop the home i would kick
the homeowner's deductible up you
already got 20 grand you can cover a
five grand deductible i would not drop
the comping collision
okay yeah i'd let that rise it's not
that bad a buy most of your savings out
of this that you're discussing is coming
from the homeowners
correct yeah i mean you're not the comp
and collision on six thousand dollar car
is not that expensive
and so yeah it's that's that's not the
big savings here and
it's you know i i i bought uh when i
discovered that
was i because i i there was a guy out
there a thousand years ago
like before i even started that i went
to one of his seminars and he always
talked about dropping comp and collision
dropping comp and self-insuring
on your vehicles and and so i was kind
of always early on when i first started
doing the show i always thought about
doing that and thought about telling
people to do that
and i bought a jeep for like four
thousand five thousand dollars and i'll
use jeep to put down at my lake house
many many years ago i don't even have
the jeep anymore it's gone
but um it was like three thousand bucks
and i got the quote on it
and and it was like a hundred dollars
or something to put comp and collision
on this little dinky
butt you know ragged jeep and i thought
you know i
i really for 100 bucks i'll do that you
know
and so it really wasn't it's worth it
and now i even look at an expensive car
and i go
it's it's worth it to cover it so i
generally cover them i've got
one vehicle that i don't have that on uh
at one of our uh vacation properties but
um
but it sits most of the time so uh
it's a little harder to justify it but
yeah i i
generally speaking if you've shopped it
with one of the endorsed local providers
and you've got a good deal on your comp
and collision i recommend keeping that
so good question though man thank you
for joining us john's in oregon hey
john what's up in your world well i have
a question for you here
um i i think i thank you for the
opportunity to talk to you and christy
um i bought a 160 acres
about 30 years ago and built it up from
scratch built the roads
the house the barn the irrigation system
the wild septic and all that sort of
stuff wow anyway
i'm at a point now where i'm thinking of
selling on 70 and
and people are interested in mine so i
wanted to know
what provisions i should consider if i
were going to try and
do a happy happy deal because i think
the banks are probably going to be
reluctant to
loan on this much property what's it
worth
probably 750 800 000
it's tough to say this is a weird market
where i'm at yeah why would a bank not
loan if somebody put down a large down
payment
well i i i really haven't talked to them
i thought they were
kind of allergic to renting on on
acreage no i mean if if somebody
they're gonna they may require 40 or 50
down or something
but you are too right
so i i i listen i i sold i don't sell a
lot of real estate when i saw peace real
estate i don't want it back
so i happy happy happy means they put
down so much that if i have to go
through the hassle of a foreclosure
then i'm happy to take it back so if
it's worth 750 000 somebody puts down
350 000 they don't pay you get it back
for 400.
you put the 350 in your pocket that you
know yeah that's probably going to make
you happy but you still gotta deal with
all the crap
that's true i'd rather not do it that
way yeah i i would rather
i would rather take a few dollars less
for the property
and then and not carry note on it
okay and i know the government has some
program where they'll
finance people but i was a little
reluctant to get into
uh that three-party deal well you don't
have to that's the buyer
right you're not gonna get that you're
not gonna get in the borrowing business
but
um yeah i i think if somebody has 350
000
down on a 750 deal they probably can get
financed
for the balance of it i i believe they
can uh
through some through something uh uh
you know again you can check some of
your local credit unions or whatever
talk to a couple realtors in the area
that are gonna maybe help you sell it
and they probably know
if they sell small pieces of land or not
small that's 160 acres
uh he says small ranch on the computer
screen here and i'm like yeah that's
that's
yeah that's a pretty good size one uh by
tennessee standards maybe not by montana
standards but anyway
so uh but yeah hey talk to your local
real estate elp they'll have a way that
the buyer can get this finance then i
wouldn't carry the note
if i were you uh because i think by the
time you get that back
in a market it's good enough as this is
right now then
you're gonna get your money you want
your money now yeah and then it's just
one less thing that you have to deal
with less stress less worry for you
brodie's in utah hi brody what's up
hey i've got a bit of a problem with a
debt collector
i've taken care of all my other debts
and i have 3 400
left on a rental
lease that was broken like three years
ago i called them
multiple times and they just they're
just rude
i i offered them 700 and they
they're just like hanging up on the
phone they don't even complete a full
sentence they
like read their little script and then
they're like okay see you click
you offered him 700 on a 3400 deal
i did okay and it's from a
a broken leash yes
okay have you talked to the original
landlord
i have not it's like a student housing
development in st george and i'm
not really certain what happens to
you're screwed
okay well you can't make someone take
less
i mean it may take 3 400 to clear it
but and rude is a technique
with the bill collector it's a technique
they're supposed to be making you upset
that's their job because when you're
upset your brain doesn't work
yeah they definitely scramble when you
get mad you do stupid stuff right
when you get your feelings hurt when
you're scared and that's what they're
trying to do they're trying to push you
back on your heels
and so just be real calm and collected
and go uh
you know call them back and go okay you
700 causes you to hang up the phone
and i understand you're being rude and
that's a technique and good luck with
that because i'm not going to get upset
so do you want some money
because i'm trying to give you some
money
and if you want some money right i told
her that too tell me what kind of money
you're you know you're gonna settle this
have they made you any kind of an offer
no okay the first time they told me pay
in full
and if you're not gonna work with us
then we're going to put it as
some throwaway line saying that you're
in trouble with
that's the crap yeah we're going to put
you in double secret probation
yeah thank you dean yeah yeah yeah
really
yeah i'm just gonna make crap up here uh
that's what they do
so yeah uh i don't know the only thing
you can do is just keep bothering them
maybe maybe you become more of a bother
to them than they are to you that would
be a fun change of pace
give them a taste of their own medicine
yeah yeah no kidding i it's been kind of
nice
being able to use that little vindictive
part of my body that's
just like ready to go channel that
energy yeah
just don't cause it to cause you to not
think because that's their job they're
trying to get you where you're
where your emotions are overriding your
wisdom
and that's where you don't want to go
good job christy thanks matt
good job ben and kelly in the booth i'm
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there is ultimately only one
way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
you